hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday June 12 2023
what's going on how are you
yeah how's it going
oh oh Billy [__] sweet tooth kicked
in last night
you know I had somebody sent me for my
it was my birthday this past weekend I
don't know 55 years old
10 years away from retirement
I finally get my Social Security that I
paid into oh boy oh boy
um did they do away with that then they
like you know we're gonna pay into this
and then you're gonna be all right
[Music]
you know
granted that was before like we learned
how to eat sort of
you know or at least they had like
Lipitor whatever those [__] Things
Are
do you want to keep eating like an
[__] and not die do you want to keep
filling your body full of poison and
never really learn about nutrition uh
that's why we made Lipitor go to Wendy's
go to McDonald's Burger King hit all
three in the same night we don't give a
[__] Lipitor Lipitor
it's just [__] holding your arteries
open like some gymnast doing an iron
cross
I don't know what Lipitor is it for your
dick I think it's a dietary I would look
it up but then for the next six months
I'm gonna get Lipitor ads
and probably my health insurance will go
up why did my health insurance go up I
didn't go in for any procedures or
anything uh you Googled Lipitor
well that was for the podcast come on
Bill we know it we know what you're
doing
you're on the road you're eating [__]
uh you know
uh one of those you know the worst thing
ever like uh is the a wet burrito is
there anything worse than a [__] wet
burrito
it's so [__] nasty with all of that
[__] like like you're not gonna be a fat
[__] enough with all the toppings you're
gonna put on it you know you want
guacamole guacamole is extra even though
you can look across the street and see a
[__] avocado tree here in Los Angeles
uh guacamole is extra
you know like it's just like it's the
1700s and they had to go to India to get
the spice it's a [__] avocado
yes but there's limes there's a lot of
other things involved
okay stay in your lane this is
agriculture all right this isn't making
fun of Agriculture which is something
you do which really if you really look
at it it's really the easiest way to go
through life you don't really do
anything as much as you just make fun of
others that are doing things
all right I mean if I didn't have to go
to work until eight o'clock at night
maybe I could have time to make some
smarter food choices and then I wouldn't
be on Lipitor
kind of sounds like a bad metal band
doesn't it
ladies and gentlemen
coming to the stage your opener for this
evening keep it going
for Lipitor
what's going on Brockton [__] you man
um
all right so anyway somebody sent me uh
for my birthday they sent me a dozen
like giant [__] cupcakes
and I looked at those things and I'm
like I don't [__] with you anymore man
you understand I don't do just I don't
eat desserts I don't [__] do it right
but it was my birthday weekend and my um
unbelievably lovely gorgeous wife took
me out
and um she got me a cake so I had the
sugar in me
you know what I'm saying people do you
understand what I'm saying I took a hit
of the crack pipe and I had that sugar
in me so now
like I I couldn't make an intelligent
choice
I could make a choice you know I thought
the sugar in me
so I looked at him I said all right
here's the deal I'm gonna have one
because I got a feeling that one on top
is red velvet all right which I love
you know what I mean it's not really the
sugar
as much as it's the food dye
[Applause]
I'm a child of the 70s all right teens
in the 80s but when I was a kid
it was all about sugar and [__] that
changed the color of your milk and food
dye and yellow number five and [__]
orange cars and bicycles everything was
[__] orange and Earth Tones it was a
[__] great time
to be a kid not a good time to be adult
I don't think you know because you
probably died with everything that was
going on there's a lot of smoke
a lot of [__] going on anyway a lot of
ashtrays ashtrays everywhere right the
waiting room of a doctor's office they
would have ashtrays
um
so I go for the red velvet and I eat it
and I went like all right I mean that
was good it wasn't great all right [__]
these I'm done I'm just gonna just give
them away and blah blah blah blah so I
have a buddy come over and I give him
one right
and uh
I don't know what happened it was like I
know what happened I took a hit of a
joint
hit who just takes a hit I had one beer
no I [__] smoked a joint and then I
came inside and I was just like and I'm
trying the chocolate one and the coconut
one I'm trying all three flavors
and uh
I woke up this morning oh my God I felt
like uh
I felt like a 55 year old that ate two
giant cupcakes right before he went to
bed this exactly I felt exactly like
what I did
and my body was just like so
is this what we're doing do we not want
to make it to 60 is that what is that
the game you know you better go get some
Lipitor what would you guys do if you
found out Lipitor advertised all right
I'm looking it up
Lipitor
this is what women with little lips take
right after they go to plastic surgery
when their lips hurt after they
stretched them out
uh Lipitor all right LIPA
tour
okay oh lipit lip l l i p i
okay all right well just [__] tell me
what it is
Lipitor
all right it's not telling me it's just
telling me the dosage what
is Lipitor
Lipitor is a prescription medicine that
contains a cholesterol-lowering medicine
I nailed it called Astro vastatin
Jesus Christ the amount of people that
wouldn't get vaccinated but we'll take
this without even questioning it
whole industry that I trust the one that
still lets me go to Jack In The Box
oh we're all Hypocrites I don't trust
the pharmaceutical company and I took
the the fire I I you know what I I
[__] rolled the dice
um
anyway I love how both sides of that are
claiming victory
getting it and not getting it I don't
know who knows who was right nobody who
got it is dying
uh you know and the thing kind of
[__] went away I want to think
because medicine sort of you know
did its best to inoculate it but I know
some people are calling it The scandemic
like it never really happened
it's fascinating anyway let's plow ahead
here so I had two [__] cupcakes Oh my
Jesus oh my Lord and save you and I went
to bed and I woke oh you know what it
was was my lovely wife is out of town on
business
and yesterday it was just me with the
kids
and uh oh my God
they [__] wore me out it was really
my son
like the amount of times I [__] lost
it yesterday
like
going like why would you do that why
would you do that he just looking at me
he just he doesn't get it yet and then I
had to be like he doesn't understand
but like that dude you leave him in a
room he's like a rock star he just goes
in and he trashes it
like if he sees a box he goes over and
he just tips it over and lets everything
pour out of it whatever food he doesn't
want he throws it on the floor
he's like immune to like you know he's
got a little chair go get over there and
sit out and think about what you did and
then he just goes over there and he's
just looking around and daydreaming like
he's just literally immune to it and
I'm sitting here uh
I don't know just thinking about the
whole way the world is set up and how
it's like male dominated and just how
guys are wired when you just see a
little girl versus a little boy and they
always say you know if women around the
world there'd be no war it's like how
would you do that you would have to undo
all this dumb [__]
basically not dumb [__] just all the
[__] that the way guys think and the guy
the way guys approach like you know
I win you lose
you know I win you're my [__] you know
that whole like
my foot's on your throat not the other
way around like how the [__] would you
flip that all of that that's like when
the old Donny boy the light he's got to
be on Lipitor eating [__] McDonald's
and when Donald Trump
made his [__] you know pay-per-view
wrestling inauguration speech and he was
saying how he was going to drain the
swamp I [__] laughed my I was like
how in the [__] are you gonna do that
first of all you're in the swamp
you and Joe Biden you know before
anybody thinks I'm doing Protestant
politics yeah
um yeah you're in the swamp but let's
just say you weren't how the [__] are
you gonna do where would you even start
um
it's really a uh
I don't know I kind of had a uh I had a
change of heart about uh like last week
as far as like um
a lot of my viewpoints and all of this
stuff
uh in other words I did mushrooms
um
I'll tell you about that trip someday
you know instead the [__] best like
every you know year or so I kind of did
him twice this year because I did a
small dose and when I went to go see
Billy Joel
which
um
was a mistake because it didn't make the
concert better
it just sort of freaked me out when I
saw a giant Billy Joel head up on the on
the big [__]
screen I was cool through Stevie Nicks
but somewhere
in the middle of Billy Joel
when he was hitting the high notes and
they were like close up on his face and
he was like you know the [__]
screen's like 180 feet
hi and you know it's one of those deals
like I knew I took mushrooms so I was
like
all right that looks like that because
you're on mushrooms
you know and then I was just thinking I
wish I didn't I just you know that thing
where they're starting to come on and
it's more of a body high
and you're just feeling almost a little
anxious that's kind of where I landed I
just sort of got there and stayed there
for four hours of like are we like I was
in the roller coaster going up the hit
up the [__] thing the whole time I'm
just anticipating this drop that never
happened
um
anyway what am I talking about I did
have time yesterday to uh
you know I I did watch game five oh my
God my
game four sorry the Stanley Cup Final my
kids are like trash me because towards
the end of the day I was finally like
I was I was watching trying to watch a
little bit of the Red Sox Yankees right
and I see them doing the highlights of
the Red Sox Yankees and they show Bucky
Dent they show Jim Rice they show Babe
Ruth I'm like where's the celebration in
when they were down four games to none
where's Big Poppy and all that and I
didn't see it and I'm sitting there
going like are they still trying to tell
this old story it's [__] over we won
four titles and we expect to win when we
play them now like why they still have
it like I understand leading up to that
but then it should just be Red Sox
[__] domination
you know for the last [__] whatever I
don't know how many years or whatever
not domination but like
given as good as we got and and the the
greatest comeback of all time and the
biggest choke
I thought the Bucky dead home run
right to the [__] Johnny Damon Grand
Slam in game seven would have been a
nice edit but you know they don't edit
that thing in Boston do they
they edit it down in [__] New York
[__]
so I'm trying to watch that and then
they're both like yelling at me and I
finally look at them I'm like what
and they started giving me [__] going
dad you're not watching us you're
watching TV and I was like are you
serious right now
I made you I made you guys egg
sandwiches for breakfast no I made you
pancakes and bacon for breakfast
okay then we went out to the bouncy
house I had to list my whole [__] day
and still it didn't mean anything to him
I was getting trashed
then I we had egg sandwiches for uh dead
breakfast all day egg sandwiches for for
lunch
I played with the choo choo train I
chased you guys around we played the
piano we did all this stuff you know
what it was was in between that I was
watching ten minute clips of uh
of game four of the Stanley Cup finals
so to them that meant I watched TV all
day because that's how they're wired
it's like
it's like how much of my time do you
need and they're like all of it
so if you spend
you know an hour and 15 minutes blowing
through commercials in the in in the in
between periods watching a game to them
it's like
you uh you watched uh you watch TV all
day [__] drove me crazy
um
but anyway I uh I did you know as much
as I'm um
telling these crazy stories it
we did have a good time and this morning
I'm downstairs and I'm making a
breakfast because I gotta take my
daughter to school oh you know also I
gave him a bath I put the [__] bath
bomb in there I [__] hate those bath
bombs they turned the the water a
different color they're bad for the
environment this one was yellow so it
looked like they were sitting in a giant
tub of [__] like nuclear urine it was
[__] disgusting and I had to wash my
daughter's hair and I'm like I'm not
washing it in that yellow [__] so then I
had to use the shower head and she's
just like that's not how Mom does it and
I'm like yeah well I'm Dad this is how
I'm doing it so we you know we got
through that
brushed out her hair I braided her hair
she looked absolutely beautiful that was
all going great and then you know this
morning I wake up
you know
my son like
comes into the room like burst in his
room he's so funny
gets on
into the bed he gets under the blankets
and I'm laying on my side like I got my
back to him he just gets in there
immediately he just starts kicking me in
the back
you know like I don't know like I said
he's running in place laying on his back
but like hitting my my back right and
then like
he gets up and he's just
like sits on my shoulder
and then puts his face like on the side
of my head and he's breathing like a
freaking obscene phone call back in the
day
and he does that for like five minutes
as I'm laying there pretending to be
asleep because I know the second I open
my eyes
the questions are coming right the
demands so I finally just opened my eyes
because it's so ridiculous
that I kind of start laughing and I look
at him and he just goes
pancakes please
dada dada pancakes please and I'm not
making your pancakes we had pancakes
yesterday for breakfast
he goes oh
and that's how my day started and then
we got downstairs and get them all
changed I get my daughter ready freshen
up her braids and everything and we go
downstairs
and I'm getting the egg sandwich ready
and then he just picked up his choo choo
train and just threw it
across the kitchen just picked it up and
just threw it
and I was like why did you do that why
did you just throw your train
huh
and he's just going trout train I go
yeah why why did you do that
and he's just looking at me like
why
why wouldn't I throw the train it's it's
fun it makes a cool sound
and I just had to sit back and be like
he doesn't understand any of this yet
and he needs like another six months of
like cognitive growth before he's gonna
get
what he should be doing so I kind of had
to just be like buddy
please don't throw your train
and he goes okay no Fortran I go yes I
go say sorry the train he's like sorry
choo choo train
so I think that that's why
I ended up smoking a joint last night
and [__] eating two giant cupcakes
because I don't drink anymore
so maybe that's what it was but uh
you know I you I pride myself on my
German Irish being able to shut off the
emotions and I can just [__]
I can get through it but holy [__]
oh you know what it was too is he
doesn't nap anymore either he just sort
of plows through the nap so I was like
all right let's do this you're just
gonna go to bed earlier and then
uh he wore me out before I wore him out
he won I had a defeat yesterday
so uh but my daughter was like super
easy
um
it's amazing she's writing in cursive
she could actually
read she actually read my son a book and
I'm thinking like man like school is
better than it was when I was a kid
because I couldn't read until like first
grade it was like Sandy and Bing Bing
and Sandy run Sandy run run run run
that's where I was at she's reading like
the whole Cat in the Hat all right I'm
bragging about my kid here all right let
me let me uh let me plow ahead I did get
a chance to watch that game for
and I'm so [__] as a fan of hockey
piss that the Panthers didn't win that
game to make it 2-2 so I could get
a series here it's now 3-1 Vegas
and uh I gotta say this I don't give a
[__] if the Panthers lose or not
because you know they're going to go out
to Vegas and they're going to win I I
just really think they're going to
they're going to go out and they're
going to win and then all of a sudden
it's like oh [__] if they win the next
one is tied three and three three to one
series lead is the most overrated series
lead ever as far as like comfort you
have as a fan
because it's all it is is all they have
to do is just win the next game
they don't have to win every single game
you know what I mean they just have to
win the next game and then all the
pressure is on the other team of like oh
[__] they win again this series is tied
up and then when they win the last one I
don't know people with three one lead
immediately goes to that
when you're the team down 3-1 all you
have to worry about is winning game five
if you win game five for the rest of the
[__] series you're playing with house
money because the other team is taking
on all the [__] pressure and um
I was like laughing watching the
Panthers yesterday and it's like playing
the Panthers is like watching two kids
by yourself
that's basically what it is it's like
right when you think you got it under
control and you can ease up and relax
you're just like oh what the [__]
that's their [__]
like I was gonna say I'm gonna go out on
a limb here I I think win or lose
uh Matthew kuchuk is the MVP of this
year's Stanley Cup playoffs
the level that that guy affects the
[__] game
like what do you need a last second goal
to tie it up and to go into overtime
an assist a big hit
do you need me to take a big hit to make
a play
and then I go to the locker room and
then I come back and I score the tying
[__] goal to send it into overtime
and then we win
do you mean do you need me to annoy one
of their best players
and get them off the ice so we have a
four on four and then we score a goal
the guy's [__]
a force of nature
um
he's sort of a medium-sized Mark Messi
it's like Mark Messier in 1994 and what
the Panthers have done is like the uh
that Great Canadian team in 1993 that
run they had to go to the cup
um it's been
so hard to watch them because
I was so upset that we [__] blew it
that's what I really was not that they
won that we [__] blew it that we
would just be like okay I think we got
the kids under control and we can put
our feet up that's what we did we had
two games one and we [__] blew it
because those guys do not stop playing
they're an amazing team and it took me
until this round to really stop being a
[__] baby about it and actually just
enjoy the level of hockey that they're
playing
um and then on the other side watching
the knights like totally nullify
that [__] [__] you know when
that that chicken [__] hockey I call it
now because there's no enforcer to come
out there and beat the [__] out of you
because you can now just after every
stop at your play if you don't if you
want to change the momentum you can
start punching guys in the head face
wash them and cross check them do all
this [__] and nothing happens and
and for the most part until the end of
the last game
but the game was over and they had won
the knights have been ignoring that
to the point that I'm seeing the
Panthers are doing it less and less
because it wasn't getting them the
desired results so it's been this little
uh
chess game is is as far as that goes and
the Knights have been doing a great job
getting traffic
in front of uh Blobby and net they keep
calling him Bob so I forget his [__]
name but um
that's really been like a uh
I think
part of the difference or whatever
but
what blows my mind is the end of the
game like the [__] Vegas Nights go up
three to nothing
and game four and I'm just sitting there
going like they need four goals they
need four goals because I know the
Panthers are going to come back and next
thing you know they just throw it on net
[__] total garbage gold you know the
flex off a stick hits hits the [__]
Vegas defenseman's like skate or his leg
and goes 90 degrees into the net right
and then the momentum's changed and this
is the thing when they were down three
nothing they never stopped playing and I
was just sitting there going they're
going to get a goal they're going to get
a goal here they always get a goal right
before the [__] period ends right and
they do even it was a garbage one but
they still you know they threw it on net
and it happened right then they come out
they get another goal now it's three to
[__] two and I'm just like this is
like
these [__] guys they're like the
Terminator they just don't stop and then
the end of the game comes
and so this would have been so legendary
somehow with like [__] point
something seconds left or whatever the
puck ends up
on kachuk's Stick
and he just couldn't get enough air
underneath it he had a wide open net in
uh Vegas Knights goalie got a got his
left pad on it and stopped it but like
I'm just sitting there thinking like
how the [__] do the Vegas Knights let
this guy get open again he just the game
before just scored the goal to tie it up
send it into overtime and you lost at
what point are you dialing in on this
guy how is he free again
you know and also the referees
at the end of the game when all the
[__] was going on and could chuck
was punching people in the face and
everything they'd always sort of start
to gram it's like when are you gonna
realize that this guy's the straw
stirring the drink
just [__] restrain them
um anyway it's been a uh
it's been
a pleasure as a hockey fan watching the
Panthers play uh they're down three to
one and I don't think this [__]
series is over
I think the Panthers go in and they win
the next one and then all of a sudden
the knights are gonna have to deal with
we got to close these [__] out
and the first time they're gonna do it
is they're gonna have to go back into
their build the Panthers building
and uh I really like the Panthers fans
too now that they showed up this year
right
um
you know I like that is like they have
trailer park fans that is not the Miami
Heat fans the you know the Miami Heat
fans is that guy of a certain age
dressed all in white linen with some
chick that's like 20 years old
oh [__] with his 300 haircut in the
[__] loafers with no socks on that
that's Miami Heat
you know I'm just talking about what I
see
Courtside all right
Courtside of a [__] Panthers game
they are [__] animals that is uh
that is that is Trailer Park Florida
and they got the rats I don't know what
that's about Rink Rats or whatever and
at the end of the game they would
[__] throwing water bottles and rats
on the ice and all that and this guy's
going like those they're not Panther
fans they're not yeah they are they are
panther fans
they are
it's you you [__] idiots you were the
ones who put a hockey team in Florida
what did you think was going to happen
I liked it I didn't think there was any
sort of bad fan Behavior I thought it
was like I bad fan Behavior to me is
when you don't act like how you usually
act and that is Florida
that's that totally lines up
um Florida's a fascinating place like I
really like Florida it reminds me of
Massachusetts it's the same thing where
you'll either have like
you know you have it's like the
combination of MIT in Harvard
and then just some [__] you know
Meathead
that you know whatever drives a truck
like all of that [__] is just right up
against each other and Florida I feel is
the same way
it's like you either own a [__] yacht
in some glass tower of a house out on
that [__] Island that JLo lives on
or you're you're literally listening to
Jimmy Buffett you know trying to kick
meth
that both of those are extremes of both
people in those States but that's why
I've always uh I always like Florida
plus when I was a kid I went to [__]
Disney World
so and I also thought palm trees were
really [__] cool for whatever reason
because when when do you ever see him
you know when you live up on the East
Coast you you know you don't
um
all right so they're up 3-1 the Denver
Nuggets are up three when I missed the
last game but uh
you know I think
I don't know I'm guessing they were just
moving the ball around hitting their
threes is always
they are a fun team to watch
uh Denver and I am psyched that it's not
the same old same old [__] people in
the finals
see I see did you guys notice how I got
both of those right Stanley Cup Final
NBA Finals how I how I remember that the
NBA Finals is plural is I just think
that like
you know with all the free agents you
can never have enough free agents you
need to add another person that's how I
remember
oh is that how you remember bill that's
fascinating Bill tell us about your
birthday nobody said all right I will
um
I uh I had a fantastic birthday
um my wife told me
um
you know I got you an experience
rather than gifts and I was like perfect
that's what I want like I literally
I got no gifts
for my birthday and it was [__]
awesome
um actually a friend of mine got me some
earplugs that you can put on your
keychain because she knew my ears are
[__] up that's the one gift I got but
other than that my uh my lovely wife
rented a uh a classic car for me to
drive around and it was a car that I
never would have picked
it was a 1969 Ford Gran Torino
now here's the deal she was trying to
get me at the 65 Cadillac that was gold
which would have been badass but it was
rented out
so she went with that instead and I
gotta tell you something man I [__]
loved that car
said it had a 351 in it it was classic
American Muscle you know it just wanted
to go really fast in a straight line you
know you get in the turns you got to
start hanging onto the underneath of the
seat so you don't slide into the [__]
door
um but it was a badass car and I felt I
felt like I was starring in like uh my
own TV show in the early 70s
you know because that was the deal like
back in the day like whoever the lead
was was definitely going to be a man for
the most part unless you're watching The
Flying Nun you know
and they always gave the guy the lead of
the show always had to have like a
badass car
and um
a Flying Nun you know they just made her
fly they didn't have to she didn't have
to have a car like you know Rockford
Files he had a uh he had a Firebird
Starsky and Hutch had the Gran Torino
Burt Reynolds had the [__] uh Trans
Am with the golden [__] bird on it
right you get the deal
Ephraim Zimbalist Jr only drove
Thunderbirds in 77 Sunset Strip yeah you
didn't think I was going to go that far
back did you
um
so
I just drove that thing around La
we went out I got some coffee at one of
my favorite places had a great breakfast
I just sort of hung out with my wife and
kids all day and then at the end of the
night
my wife took me out to this cigar bar
that I didn't even know existed
and um
we just had like the best time and I I
had like
it was perfect
you know and I was just thinking like
you know maybe this is what you do
rather than owning classic cars you just
rent them and you drive around and you
have a great [__] time
and then
you just give them back
then you kind of can have all the cars
you know that's kind of how I'm looking
at it now it was like but I just loved
like you know the uh
when you put the gas in it was behind
the license plate just those little
things that had the lap belts it was a
convertible I never you know I've never
been a ragtop guy you know obviously
[__] Ginger I burn up in the sun and
it was a cloudy day and I [__] loved
it
I absolutely love the top down and the I
what I noticed the car had no vents
you know back in the day when they made
convertibles they're just like we don't
need vents put the [__] top down what
do you want [__] you know it's pretty
rough time I don't think they really
talk like that but um
underrated the 1969 Gran Torino I gotta
jump off the podcast here I got to do a
uh a quick Zoom call here which doesn't
mean [__] to you guys because it'll be a
quick edit but uh
reminding myself to continue talking
about my birthday
and I
um all right so
what's up blah blah blah so both the
Stanley Cup and the NBA final of course
you know
already you already know I don't need it
I don't need to tell you this [__]
all right
I don't want to say it again both series
are three to one
um and then that's going to be it and
then we're going to be in a baseball
season everybody's gonna be like
baseball I love it
I enjoy it
um
and
I got to start watching the Red Sox
because I haven't watched them in a
minute last time I checked in on them
they were two games above 500 yet still
in last place
still in last place
so uh
oh you know what I [__] can't stand
do you ever notice like guys who can't
get hot women they love to say this [__]
they love to say like you know you show
me a beautiful woman
and I'll show you guys tired of [__]
it right my whole life I heard people
saying that
show me a beautiful woman and I'll show
you a a a a guy that's tired of [__]
you and I want to be like yeah and I'll
show you a guy that got with her for the
wrong reasons how about that you dumb
[__]
I am whatever that dude is I am so sick
of that dude like I saw this [__]
idiot
on Instagram and he was go he was just
saying this [__] like uh
he was going like I get up at like I
start my day
from like I go from 6 to 12
and then I blah blah then the next day I
start my day at like 3 A.M then the next
day I start my day at 12 a.m see so I
just added an extra day end of the week
I'm like what what happened you added a
day
thank you
did you also find the H chord on the
guitar what else did you do what the
[__] right he's like I just did he goes
after week he goes I'm making stride he
goes after a month he goes I'm kicking
your ass
that's what he said in the video I'm
kicking you kicking my ass what game are
we playing what are we even competing in
he goes over a year's time I'm over the
[__] Mountain blah blah blah and what
I love
what I love about the clip is at no
point does he even say what business
he's in what he's doing what he's
accomplishing
I feel like those people
all of those people out there who are
saying this ridiculous [__] that they
wake up at two in the morning to [__]
work out
and they start their day so they can be
on a business call with Berlin Germany
or whatever the [__] philosophy is
um I feel like they are the modern day
like remember those televangelists
um that was like the big fling flam you
know which that ended up creating one of
my favorite characters
of all time in wrestling uh brother love
because ah
um
brother love uh yeah those [__] guys
who are just sitting there where they
they they talk about uh how to set up
relationships with women
I always talk about this guy in the
first date I sat down
with my now wife and I said I'm just
gonna tell you right now
I will not give up on my dream like who
the [__] says that on like the first
date
like this hope like posturing and
getting yourself into like a position
and all of that gets it's this whole
whole [__] [__]
mindset I feel like that we're all in
you know just walking around like I'm
winning so you're my [__] like there's
no like coexisting or anything like that
and with I don't know we're just [__]
I don't know
[__] destroying each other and it's
so dumb and I think the fact that like
if you're a guy like
the less you feel feelings and the more
you don't give a [__]
the more you like admired
[Music]
really a uh
it's really a [__] up thing because
all you do is hear the ladies talking
about all their [__] and all the stress
that they're under and wada and I have
to have the thigh gap and all of this
stuff and I I just don't want to do it
every day I just don't want to do it
right and they were able to cry and get
it out of them and all we got like our
self-help guys are going like you know
what I get up before you do
you know and I had an extra day and then
your [__] toast I'm kicking your ass
and I'm like how am I losing this fight
I don't know what the [__] fight I'm
even in
um
I so want to comment on those things but
like
I just know that it never goes well
whenever you like jump whenever you join
the like you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna leave a comment
um
so instead what I do is I say my
comments on my podcast while torturing
you as you're trying to [__] uh I'll
tell you right now you show me a hot
woman uh so you guys tired of [__]
you know what I think I'm doing I think
you're showing me a guy that's afraid to
talk to a beautiful woman
huh and if you got one you'd be afraid
to let her be yourself and go out and do
the [__] that she wants to do you know
not saying that guys do that exclusively
because I don't want any woman out there
listening right now thinking I'm
becoming a feminist I'm not I realize
you know this is my feminism you guys
are just as out of your [__] mind as
we are
um but if you're lucky and you get a
great one
you know you could really learn about
yourself
as a man which I feel like I did with
the woman that I'm with
um who is beautiful and no I ain't tired
I'm sorry
um have a little respect huh all right
game time everybody all right oh I like
this one game time all right buying
tickets to your favorite events
shouldn't be stressful game time it's
the fast and easy way to buy tickets for
all sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over the tickets
and start getting hyped for the fun
you'll have I'm gonna try this [__]
because I always use that other one that
I'm probably not supposed I'm probably
not allowed to say
that rhymes with GrubHub
um
because that one is stressful
um game time is the place for last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
it's the fastest growing ticket app in
the country for a reason get images of
your seat before you buy so you know
exactly what to expect when you arrive
buy tickets in a matter of seconds this
is what I like two Taps and you're set
tickets are sent directly to your phone
so you never have to dig through your
email I'm loving that snag tickets
without stress with
with game time download game time app
download the game time app create an
account and use the code Burr for twenty
dollars off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code Burr bur for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
and then the only other read we have is
movement
mvmt Great Moments with Dad are worth
remembering give him a Father's Day gift
he'll never forget a movement watch
movement small team of dreamers
dream Weavers we will make a watch that
you can buy your dad head dad I got you
watch man thank you son
uh mvt small team of dreamers in Venice
Beach California have perfected Sleek
original Ultra Clean watch design and
with their site-wide Father's Day Sale
you'll get a great price on a gift as a
one-of-a-kind as one of a kind as dad is
time is a meaningful sentiment show the
dads in your life how much you
appreciate all the time they've given
you they look at the watch and think of
you every day perfect for a Father's Day
gift pair dad's new watch with MV mt's
pronounced movements stunning minimalist
jewelry so you both have a daily
reminder of your bond
wait a minute what I get him a watch and
what I buy myself a [__] bracelet I
almost said a trust bracelet is that a
thing
uh
a commitment [__]
Ascot I don't know fast shipping and
returns always why movement is a great
watch fresh modern designed by a team of
weekend Mavericks who know what it means
to go from nine to five work days to
five to nine good times and every
Adventure in between the
the epitome of bang for your buck with
huge value and style your wrist and
wallet will both love get him a Father's
Day gift as memorable as he is from
movement get up to 40 percent off at
mvmt.com Michael Victor Michael
tango.com and use code Bill Burr
exclusions May apply that's movement
mvmt.com code Burr b-u-r-r for up to 40
off
you guys have a listen to the
Dreamweaver album
that's a [__] killer album now the
single was it Gary Wright is that who it
is Dreamweaver
um
somebody get me a judge and the other
one
[Music]
uh
good good
whatever
I think it's time to get ready
he's on fire
okay I'm not gonna remember it sorry um
all right let's let's read something
from Sweden you'll never get that 30
seconds back let me try to remember that
song
uh Sweden uh hello Bill
big fan I just bought your tickets to
the show in Sweden I just want you to
promise me something don't hold back on
the Proud feminist socialist swedes keep
on tracking
um come to my
come to my house we'll have a party
I'll never forget that the creepiest
Heckle I ever got
come to my house and have a party
I was asking them what is there to do
here in Sweden and you know
that's that's what came back come to my
house we'll have a party
it's like will I be wearing a [__] suit
um
don't hold back on the Proud feminist
socialist swedes
socialistic swedes uh
I won't but I like you guys I mean I
don't know
I have like a different viewpoint
of feminism than actual feminists do
I think like active feminists when
they're running their yaps they just
sound like dumb guys with but they have
vaginas
it's like you sound like the exact same
power hungry [__] lunatics
who pretend that they give a [__] about
the pin the people beneath them but you
don't
um that's what you are that'd be a tough
pill for a lot of them to swallow
you know no pun intended
that was not a pro-choice statement it
was just an expression I was using
that if they realized that at the end of
the day they were Donald Trump with a
vagina
[Music]
just as arrogant just as stupid
just as unqualified
um but say what you want about Donald
Trump
he has his faculties
as opposed like dude what can they just
put Joe Biden on a [__] porch
somewhere
and just let the guy enjoy the last
couple months of his life like what are
we doing with this guy I mean
it is [__] unbelievable I I truly do
believe that the media is liberal like
the level that they're letting this guy
get away with like just
you know stopping in the middle of
speeches I mean I can't even [__]
watch it
um
I think all of us as Americans we really
owe it
to both sides to our side what why why
there's sides I don't know why we owe it
to humanity
to pick somebody qualified
all right
we
one side had their [__] idiot the
other side had their [__] idiot like
let's just go back to somebody that can
deliver a [__] speech
would be nice you know what I mean
um
it won't happen
all right birthday Barry and root beer
Billy birthday boy we almost share a
birthday I turned I turned 29 on June
9th happy birthday mildly funny story
because my head crowned
because of because my head crowned on
June 8th
at 11 59 pm and the birthing process
finished past
midnight on June 9th my mom got to
choose either date for my birthday
she chose June 9th because it meant
insurance covered an extra day in the
hospital smart lady I like that work in
the system
anyways he writes your cameo in Barry
as the pot Coast host saying murder is
definitely not a sin crack me the [__]
up I'm so glad people like that because
I had no idea what they were going to do
with it I just went down and did the
voice over obviously I had not seen the
episode but the people that were
directing me
sent me in the right direction but that
was definitely one of those ones I was
walking out going like I hope that works
but then I was like well it's Bill Hader
he's a [__] genius so even if I [__]
this up
he'll either make it work or just not
use it so I felt that was in good hands
so thank you
for the people that watched it and sent
me
um
the compliments but it should go to Bill
Hader and his writing staff because I
just said what they wrote okay here we
go it's funny to think that in an
alternate universe you might be a deadly
hockey enforcer and a religious nut and
still a successful podcast host
yeah but I mean I would have to have
played in like the 19 teens to actually
be an enforcer with my size
my middleweight size uh lastly for three
years during High School
I worked at an A and W in Detroit ah
if I see one of those on the road
because they're they're barely there
anymore I I literally have to stop and
get something it's my favorite burger
stand
in the world because they didn't have
them on the east coast and whenever I
would go out to like the Midwest or
something I don't even know when I
started seeing them maybe when I started
doing the road
I couldn't believe it I was like
a w has their own burger stand this is
like because most places don't even
carry root beer
It's [__] amazing anyway while I
myself may not be a root beer nut I
absolutely love the root beer flavored
soft serve ice cream at a w seriously
that [__] rocks treat yourself a little
for your for our birthday much love to
you and your family and thanks for all
the laughs you read son of a [__] uh go
[__] yourself uh all right thank you
um
all right catch-22
all right catch 22. dear shiny head bill
I do have a shiny head
you know and it's not because I'm bald
that's my personality shining through
the top of my hairless head uh you're a
long time listener first time Carla
um
I was listening to try to explain the
origin and meaning of Catch-22 and had
to write in yeah I didn't I had never
seen the movie and I was unfamiliar so
thank you for writing in to set me
straight here in the book the soldiers
are required to complete
uh all right so anyway there's the
expression catch-22
which I thought it meant damned if you
do damned if you don't
evidently it it it I think it kind of
meant regardless of your response
you know if you choose a or b c is still
happening so it doesn't matter but they
give you the illusion of choice I don't
know this person will explain it in the
book
the soldiers are required to complete a
certain number of missions in order to
be released from their duties from what
I remember the missions are World War II
bomber missions and are extremely
dangerous and the shoulders so soldiers
have to complete 40 of them if a soldier
agrees to go on a mission the soldier is
labeled as clinically insane
and they are not allowed to fly because
no one in their right mind would agree
to go on such a Dangerous Mission if you
don't want to fly then the office
officers agree that is the right
response and they deem the soldiers sane
and tell them to fly the mission the
soldier agrees to the mission
and is immediately called insane again
and they ground you from flying thus
creating the paradox
an inability to complete the required
missions
these soldiers are never able to reach
their goal and even if someone does get
close to commanding officers raise the
requirement
well it kind of seems like they're
looking out for you the phrase Catch-22
is mentioned when the characters talk
about this one catch to the rules that
they have to follow in order to go home
the book was originally titled catch 18
but the offer changed it since a
different
World War II novel came out around the
same time with the number 18 in the
title 22 was chosen because it has a
repeating number numbers similar to
repeating events that happen in the book
love the podcast and go [__] yourself
well thank you very much for a very
clear and well-written
explanation of crutch 22.
uh The Catch 22 I have with that is that
still doesn't quite make sense to me
because they actually looked out for you
I thought it was no matter what you're
going on this mission
and you're gonna [__] die
seems like it went the other way
I don't know wrong expressions
all right if you guys are new to the
podcast this is something that I've been
doing as of late which is uh
talking about people using uh
Expressions incorrectly or my favorite
combining
combining expressions
um
all right hi Bill heard this one the
other day they took their foot off the
boil
what does that mean I don't even
took their foot off the gas
anyway the person says I believe this
beauty is the bastard son of the
expression they took
their foot off the gas and go off the
boil
thought you'd appreciate this one thanks
and go take a flying [__] to yourself
wait a minute I never heard of the go
off the boil that sounds European to me
hang on a second
what is Lipitor we have to get rid of
this
okay to go off the boil
meaning
all right British informal
into a state that is less good than
before after two hits singles the band
went off the boil and eventually
disbanded all right origin
origin
[Music]
it's a weird word origins origin
uh to lose interest or become less
urgent they were really excited about
the project but now they've seem to go
off the boil
oh the pot was boiling is that what it
is
who the [__] is that
I found this on the web all of a sudden
it just started talking like it's let's
stop [__] listening to me get a life
you AI [__]
uh originally an expression of the
kitchen if you have to boil some
substance in in hot water for a long
time
the fire goes out
wait a minute this is interesting we're
talking this is before
you had gas
in the thing here
when the bubble wears it
origin
etymology how the [__] do you say that
word
and I'm trying to work my way around
this except all cookies necessary
cookies only
like how do I even know what cookies
you're using I don't give a [__] when
the bubbles stop coming up a previously
boiling liquid is said to have gone off
the boil this happens after heating is
stopped but not immediately there is
always a delay because
caused by thermal
hysteresis
it doesn't only mean pass the crisis it
is frequently used to mean something is
not performing as well as it did
all right okay so you could say
something's off the boil
meaning
you know how are you and your wife doing
ah better man we're off the boil I guess
you could do it like that or off the
boil as far as like a band where you are
a hot band
churning out hit singles and all of a
sudden you cooled off
with a couple of stinkers and then
you're off the boil
I took my foot off the boil yeah okay I
get it now you brought me into your
English word world yes that is a
bastardized version of we just don't say
that around here
um I'm gonna start doing it just to see
if my wife uh
picks up on it
um at some point I'm gonna have her on
this on this podcast to talk about we
took a mushroom trip together it was
like her first time like
really tripping or whatever so it was
it was really fun to watch
um
and uh sort of experience all that I
gotta have her on the podcast it was a
definitely an amazing uh an amazing time
so with that I am not
having a cupcake today
even though I ate three my buddy had one
that means there's eight left
so I'm gonna give these things away
um
make sure I don't [__] uh
I can't think I'm Billy's fat tits I've
worked too goddamn harm you know what
sucks I had a personal trainer and I was
killing it but now I have to do physical
therapy because my my one of my
shoulders you can literally move it in
the socket you know like an inch this
way and an inch that way so they got to
fix that they have to stabilize it my
ligaments are are loose they got
stretched out or some [__]
so I don't know how they tighten them up
um but I gotta do that over the next
like month or so and then I get back in
the gym so in the meantime I've just
been doing like uh
just making sure I've been stretching or
whatever there's a couple of stretches I
always wanted to be able to do
um you know like those Bruce Lee ones
where you're sitting down and your head
just can go right down to your kneecaps
you know
I always thought that was cool I can do
the one where you put your arm behind
your back and then reach over with your
other one and Clash hands I can do that
on both sides
uh so the shoulders are good
um well pill maybe because that's the
problem do you ever think that that's
the problem do you ever think that
you're not a [__] rehab person that
rehabs shoulders
um all right that is the podcast
everybody my prediction
my prediction I feel that the uh
the Florida Panthers are going to stay
alive in the Miami Heat unfortunately
are going to lose
um
and somebody's trying to tell me they
think Jimmy Butler's hurt not trying to
make excuses
but uh I really like that [__]
organization and but I'm psyched though
for the Denver Nuggets they've never won
an NBA title evidently they won an ABA
title like 50 years ago
so that's great it is funny though like
I thought their fan base would seem more
like newbies like oh my God I can't
believe we're in the finals but uh they
act like a bunch of arrogant [__] too
everybody's just [__] holding the
jersey and doing that [__] stupid
Instagram
like I don't even know what it is it's
like uh
everybody walks around acting like a
heel in wrestling I feel like back in
the day like the only people that
behaved that way
I felt well like you know like Ric Flair
now everybody's walking around with like
Ric Flair vibes
uh which is so funny because they're not
even at least Ric Flair was doing some
[__] you're watching it
like you're the Ric Flair of fans like I
don't even understand it that's because
you're all built
you're old and the world has passed you
by and you just haven't accepted it yet
all right I'll go with that
um all right so that's my prediction the
Florida Panthers win
game five
bring it back to Florida
for an unbelievable game six which I
think the Vegas Knights might win
because I I just think that they are
they they don't get involved into the
head games they keep their [__] cool
um
I don't know whatever but I think Miami
Heats are going to lose game five cheat
Bill why don't you just sit here and add
another [__] nine minutes to the
podcast saying the same thing over and
over again all right that's the podcast
go [__] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday